it's a cold autumn night sometime around
the late 1870s somewhere in the Western
District of Arkansas the West can't get
any wilder than it is here you're on the
run from the lure and you've got a
sentence hanging over your head issued
by none other than the infamous federal
judge Isaac Parker known as the hanging
judge
he has dispatched his most effective and
relentless enforcer to bring you back to
justice a lawman so feared and respected
that he haunts criminals in their
nightmares
how would you picture him in your hat
well you're probably thinking about your
typical cowboy complete with Stetson hat
a six-shooter and a star-shaped badge
popularized by Hollywood tall like Gary
Cooper strong like John Wayne rugged
like Clint Eastwood and full of grit
like Jeff Bridges well you got it all
right except for one detail your nemesis
is a freed former african-american slave
bass Reeves the first black deputy US
Marshal to ride for justice west of the
Mississippi River today his life
bass Reeves was born into slavery on the
16th of July 1838 in Crawford County
Arkansas basket his first name from his
grandfather bass Washington and his
surname from the Arkansas State
Legislature William Steele Reeves who
owned bass Reeves and his family in 1846
his master moved to Grayson County Texas
where young bass first worked as a
stable hand and a blacksmith's
apprentice before becoming a manservant
to the son of his master George Reeves
this George Reeves was quite a
high-profile character being the Speaker
of the House in the Texas Legislature
and later a Confederate colonel during
the American Civil War bass did actually
follow him everywhere joining him in
several battles bass himself claims to a
fort peerage in March 1862 Chickamauga
in September of 1863 and Missionary
Ridge in November of 1863 now we will
see later on how bass Reeves achieved
some outstanding accomplishments in his
later life and yet the man must have
felt the needs to fluff up his military
record in newspaper interviews according
to his great grand nephew Federal Judge
Paul Brady as did fights at the peerage
battle which by the way was a major
Confederate defeats but he disputes
Bass's participation in the other
battles you see some time after peerage
bass ended disagreements over a game of
cards with Colonel Reeves
that's terminated his working
relationship with the colonel with the
only means he had available at that time
and that was a punch to the Colonel's
face that was the beginning of bass
Reeves is legend
with a serious prospect of death by
lynching bass fled north to Indian
Territory modern-day Oklahoma not far
from peerage during this period he lived
with the Cherokee Seminole and Creek
Indians becoming fluent in the Muscogee
language as well as learning languages
spoken by other tribes he did not
entirely escape from the war though
historian dr. art Burton suggests that
bass may have become unionists
sergeant's after joining a unit made up
of former slaves and Native Americans
fighting against tribes allied to the
Confederacy the Emancipation declaration
was issued in 1863 followed at the end
of the Civil War by the ratification of
the Thirteenth Amendment to the United
States Constitution which definitively
abolished slavery bass was now a free
man and he was able to settle in
Arkansas becoming a farmer near Van
Buren it was here that he met and
married his first wife Nellie Jenny from
Texas with whom he had ten children five
boys and five girls Reeves and his
family farmed in Van Buren until 1875 so
what was life like for an
african-american family in the southern
states at that time well as you might
imagine it was not very easy the early
post-war years were promising for
african-americans the federal Freedmen's
Bureau ensured that by 1870 more than
240,000 black pupils were enrolled in
more than 4,000 schools then the
Fifteenth Amendment granted all males
the right to vote regardless of race
color or previous condition of servitude
within a few years every southern state
legislature had african-american members
and eleven african-americans had been
elected to US Congress by 1875
unfortunately when federal troops left
the occupied southern states former
Confederates returned to power and
rescinded many of the rights gained by
African Americans they were forbidden to
vote to testify in court against
European Americans who enrolled in
schools who travel freely to disobey an
order or to leave a job without
permission
in many states any African American
traveling alone could be arrested or
sentenced to forced labor new codes of
social segregation came into being as
European and African Americans were
forced into separate accommodations to
an extent even greater than during
slavery this harsh social order became
infamous as the Jim Crow laws enforced
by new vigilante organizations like the
Ku Klux Klan which terrorized African
Americans and tortured and killed those
who violated the new codes lynching it
became
commonplace the district of Kansas must
have been a dangerous and precarious
world for bascinets family back then
however Reeves had a very valuable
talent you see the nearby Indian
Territory was the favorite hiding place
for hundreds of desperados bandits on
the run from federal and local Norman it
was an expensive land so lethal and
lawless that historian art Burton
compared it to Afghanistan post
insurgency you could lose your life over
your hat your horse your gun your women
any damn thing while bass Reeves was
literally at home in this hell on earth
he knew the territory he was on friendly
terms with the native tribes and he
could speak their language soon this
talent was recognized and he was hired
as a guide by the u.s. marshal stationed
in Van Buren when venturing into Indian
Territory
[Music]
so those of you who are not watching
from the US you might be asking well
yeah but who exactly are these marshals
who you're talking about Simon well the
office of the u.s. marshals was created
in 1789 by the first ever American
Congress their function was to support
the federal courts within their judicial
districts and to carry out all lawful
orders issued by judges Congress or the
presidents in practical terms this
included some pretty badass and
life-threatening activities such as
paying expenses to the court clerks
hiring court janitors insuring witnesses
were on time and oh the horror refilling
water pitchers for judges attorneys and
jurors but don't worry the life it
wasn't all thrills in fact the u.s.
marshals were given the power to appoint
deputies who had the power to carry out
the most mundane and clerical of tasks
like apprehending murderers fugitives
escorting prisoners across dangerous
territories carrying out arrest warrants
arresting criminals on the spot and
supporting local law enforcement in
their normal duties but I might have got
those lists in the wrong order
either way the point is the US Marshals
had and still have huge and varied
responsibilities and we're often in the
front line of the war against crime in
the lawless lands west of the
Mississippi River this is especially
true because at the time they and the
private detectives from Pinkerton were
the only law enforcement agencies with
federal jurisdiction now let's hear from
Burton again the Indian Territory was
where the majority of deputy US Marshals
had been killed in the line of duty in
the history of the Marshal Service
you're looking at a little over 200 have
been killed in the line of duty to this
date right now on records over a hundred
and thirty were killed in the Indian
Territory you also had Indian policemen
getting killed who had town municipal
policemen getting kills it had to be the
greatest battlegrounds between crime and
law in the history of the United States
of America
[Applause]
in 1875 former US congressman Isaac
Parker was appointed federal judge for
the Indian Territory Parker became known
as the hanging judge for his propensity
to hands out harsh death sentences he
was a harsh man but apparently that's
what West Arkansas ins the Indian
Territory needed
Parker appointed James F Fagan as US
Marshal directing him to hire 200 US
Marshal deputies Fagan had heard about
Reeves and how he knew the Indian
Territory and could speak several Indian
languages and he decided to deputize him
it is tempting to celebrate bass Reeves
as the first African American US Deputy
Marshal but he was not he may have been
the first or maybe he was just one of
the first west of the Mississippi our
expert dr. Burton in fact claims that
the presence of black lawmen and
soldiers in the Old West has been
grossly underrepresented by historians
and popular culture alike
if we look at the real western frontier
you also found blacks who were in law
enforcement across the West in Montana
and Colorado and New Mexico 20 percent
of the military on the western frontier
were African Americans further the
majority of the federal workers for the
Fort Smith Court Arkansas in 1878 were
African Americans so why do we celebrate
and remember bass Reeves today not only
because he was one of those who had
overcome barriers imposed by prejudice
by segregation and sometimes even by law
which today would count as crimes
against humanity not only that but also
because he was simply one of the best
damn woman who ever lived
period
[Music]
and in the role of one of the finest
lawman ever bass Reeves certainly looked
the part he cut an impressive figure
standing at 6 foot 2 or 188 centimeters
sporting an epic handlebar moustache
black Stetson hat and dark polished
boots he was an accomplished horseman
and marksman due to his hunting and
military experience and life as a
blacksmith and farmer had made him
incredibly strong but Reeves he was not
all brawn even though he remains
illiterate his whole life deputy Reeves
had a prodigious memory so he just
learned by heart of the warrants and
court orders as he received them he
could also be very cunning preferring to
use guile instead of guns in many
occasions and had reportedly developed
some seriously impressive detective
skills his track record speaks for
itself over the course of his career as
a deputy marshal from 1875 to 1907 bass
Reeves carried out 3,000 arrests that's
an average of 94 per year he also shot
and killed 14 criminals in self-defense
but was never seriously wounded despite
his hat being shot off two separate
times but let's take a closer look at
some of his most famous adventures in
September 1884 deputy Reeves was in the
Indian Territory with arrest warrant in
hand for two rustlers Frank bark and
John Bruner to local merit volunteered
to guide him but unbeknownst to him
these guys were actually Barkin Bruner
while camping for dinner
Reeves noticed Bruner reaching for his
pistol the marshal wouldn't have it he
quickly grabbed Bruna's gun and pulled
his own six-shooter behind his back buck
was getting ready to shoot quiz a flash
and still holding Bruna's weapon Reeves
turned around and shot buck dead in
another case Reeves had to face the
famous three outlaw brothers the
branches but this time it seemed like
the criminals have the upper hands they
ambushed Reeves and held him at gunpoint
taunting the man who was already known
as the indomitable marshal the fearless
as usual Reeves calmly asked for the
date when the brothers asked why Reeves
explains that their arrest papers needed
to be datas after all they were coming
with him dead or alive in a scene worthy
of a Hollywood action movie The Outlaws
burst out laughing Reeves took advantage
of their distraction turning away from
the barrel of the gun aimed at him the
other two brothers aimed at him as well
but Reeves was quicker on the draw and
shot both debt as for the third brother
some accounts tell us that Reeves took
him into custody according to others the
remaining bronzor had some fight left in
him until Reeves disarmed him and
cracked his skull with his own gun
but as I mentioned earlier Reeves was
not just about fists and bullets he
could also be sly as a fox during the
pursuit of two outlaws in the Red River
Valley Reeves and his colleague thought
the criminals were seeking refuge at
their mother's cabin approaching old
Momma's House on the open terrain was
too dangerous but Reeves had a plan
he dirtied up his clothes ditched his
polished boots for an old pair of shoes
and shot three holes in his hat he then
walked 28 miles to the cabin and knocked
on the door when Mom open the door
Reeves impersonated an outlaw on the run
from the marshals who was thirsty hungry
and tired of course the old lady
sympathized and took him in later that
night her boys showed up and she
whistled to them indicating that the
coast was clear when the other marshals
arrived the next morning they found
Reeves keeping watch on the two brothers
still asleep and safely handcuffed
without firing a shot nor risking
anyone's life Reeves had scored a
resounding victory collecting a $5,000
reward which is about one hundred
twenty-one thousand dollars in today's
money and yet despite Reeves is
undisputed effectiveness some white
Norman still believed that a black man
was beneath them Judge Brady Reeves his
great grand nephew reports one incidence
in which a white police officer
threatened to shoot the marshal with his
gun for ordering some white federal
prisoners around in other words being
guilty of doing his job
only the intervention of a senior
marshal avoided a shootout amongst
fellow lawman
Vasari's fame grew with each arrest
fueled by local newspapers in search of
heroes to celebrate his reputation as a
fearless indomitable incorruptible
lawman eventually became a deterrent
enough to prevent criminals from
escaping justice just listen to this
story from the summer of 1903 one night
a man called Jerry McIntosh had dragged
his wife out of bed during a drunken
rage he had doused her in oil and set
her on fire leaving her alive but in
critical condition McKenzie was quick to
leave town but while on the run he had a
dream or rather a nightmare according to
the July 16th 1980 edition of The Daily
ad marette McKenzie says he dreams last
night the deputy marshal reeves came
upon him in the brush and when he jumped
up to run the deputy shot and killed him
when he awoke and realized that it was
only a dream he decided to come to town
and give up immediately
bass Reeves steely dedication to
upholding the Lord did not hold him back
from his friends or family either he
famously arrested the minister that had
baptized him on charges of selling
illegally Katan and even more famously
he went after his own son Benny here is
the daily armor at again a warrant for
the arrest of the younger Reeves for
murdering his wife has been issued and
marshal Bennett said that perhaps
another deputy had better be sent to
serve it old bass was in the room and
quietly said give me the wrist he went
out arrested his son brought him to
court and saw a jury try and convict him
and sentenced him to life imprisonment
Benny Reeves was eventually freed from
his life sentence for being a moral
prisoner and reportedly never committed
another crime again now so far we've
looked at the highlights of Reeves his
career but in his tenure as marshal
there was at least one shadow in April
of 1884 Reeves had in fact been involved
in the death by shooting at his camp
cook William leach an initial inquest
ruled that this had been an accident and
no charges were filed against deputy
Reeves but two years later a former
Confederate to go over the u.s.
attorney's office and the sentence was
overruled vos was now charged with
murder stripped of his badge and held in
jail for more than three months Reeves
and others testified that the shooting
was accidental with his rifle going off
while Reeves was trying to clear a
faulty cartridge from the chamber with a
knife he was eventually acquitted but
illegal expenses left him financially
ruined as he was forced to sell his home
according to judge Jim Spears a member
of the bass Reeves Legacy initiative the
charges against the deputy marshal were
politically and
motivators however Reeves a strength of
character is shown by the fact that he
decided to continue his career after his
acquittal and so the lone Marshall wrote
again and became the legend that we know
of today for some time he was believed
to be the inspiration behind the
character of the lone ranger masked
lawman in the Old West first appearing
in a 1930s radio show then a 1950s TV
series as well as comics cartoons and
several movies but I'm afraid to tell
you that this is actually a myth that
can be safely debunked as it was
circulated by none other than our
friends dr. art Burton who hinted at
this connection without any real proof
The Lone Ranger was actually inspired by
the myth of Robin Hood and by Tom Mix
a star of early Western films rather
than saying the bass inspired some
masked white dude in a lame 2013 movie
doesn't he deserve a proper well written
well produced and not straight-to-video
film
[Music]
the Wild West lost much of its
wilderness in the early 20th century as
America fulfilled its manifest destiny
and the Pacific coast was conquered by
settlers by 1907 Kansas Arkansas and
Oklahoma had officially become States
within the Union and the Indian
Territory with its ongoing war against
the law was Auburn in memory bass Reeves
was now aged 68 and it was time for him
to leave the u.s. marshals but he did
not retire just yet preferring to serve
for a further two years as a police
officer in the Muscogee Police
Department in 1909 the tireless Reeves
finally did retire due to a kidney
condition called Bright's disease he
died a year later on January the 12th
1910 being remembered in his obituary as
a universally respected US Deputy
Marshal who was absolutely fearless and
had no known master but duty so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe we got brand new videos four
times a week so subscribe hit that
notification bell you'll find out when
we put out those new videos and as
always thank you for watching
you